Prof: So I'm going to
talk about what led up to the
crisis and how the crisis makes
us realize that the things about
the theory that we've been
learning all semester that ought
to be slightly different,
and I've been working on a new
version of the theory for the
last ten years,
what I call the Leverage Cycle,
which I have to say didn't get
very much attention ten years
ago,
but which now seems to be,
I don't know,
it seems to be getting more
attention.
It's almost like life imitated
art, really.
It couldn't have turned out
more like the theory than I
would have expected.
So I'm going to tell you the
facts and then try to fit a
theory to it,
and probably will spill over
until Thursday,
and I think Thursday I won't
spend that much time finishing.
I'll have a review class if
anyone's interested for the
whole material.
And I think when you see the
critique of the theory it might
help put the theory in a little
bit more perspective.
But anyway, nothing of what I
say these last two days you
should feel is going to be on
the exam.
It's just more information that
you might find interesting.
So we talked last time,
remember, at one of those
special classes about the
sub-prime mortgage market,
and the idea was that you would
pool together a bunch of loans.
These are the--I can do this,
I guess.
You'd pool together a bunch of
individual mortgages like this,
and then you'd put them in a
giant pool,
and then cut the pool up into a
triple-A bond,
a double-A bond,
a single-A bond,
a triple-B bond,
and this is the over
collateralization and the
residual.
And I'm not going to go through
the whole structure,
but suffice it to say that the
idea of this is you take
individual loans which are very
risky,
after all these are sub-prime
borrowers so everyone knew that
they were risky,
and you create what's supposed
to be an incredibly safe bond.
The definition of triple-A bond
is that it has a 1 in 100 chance
of going bankrupt in 10 years,
of losing any principal in 10
years.
That was the definition they
claimed.
I heard a talk about power
failures last night,
by the way, the power grid
which went out all across from
Cleveland to Manhattan in 2003,
and they said that was an event
that should happen once every 10
years.
And then when you hear what
happened in the event,
someone didn't trim a tree,
and the line sagged into the
tree,
and so then it shut itself off,
and then the city next door
they had the same problem with
someone not trimming a tree,
and that line shut off,
and once you have two or three
lines shut off the system
automatically goes down.
It seems like it could happen
much more often than once every
10 years.
But anyway, it's the same thing
here.
This is supposed to be once
every 10 years,
1 in 100 chance,
and it happened in a giant way.
So the idea of the triple-A,
so they're supposed to very
safe because if the first house
defaults,
the first homeowner defaults,
instead of paying back the 100
he owes,
let's say he just stops paying,
and then you throw the guy out
of the house,
but then you get to sell the
house.
The house is there as
collateral for the loan.
Now, the loan should have been
100.
The house should have been
worth much more than the 100.
That's why it should have been
collateral.
So you should have had 120
dollars of the house to sell so
even if the house went down by
33 percent to 80 that's still
only a 20 dollar loss,
or let's say 20 cent loss on
the dollar loan,
and that 20 cents comes out of
the triple-B piece.
So you notice how many losses
do you have to have if you're
losing 20 cents on a house?
To have 5 dollars worth of
losses you've got to have 25 of
the 100 houses go down,
and another 25 of the houses
have to go down to lose this
one,
and then another whole bunch of
them,
35 more to go down.
So you've got to have like 85
houses going down before you
touch the triple-A,
because the losses always come
from the bottom and work their
way up.
So when they made these deals
they thought it was
inconceivable that you'd have 85
percent of the houses
defaulting,
or that you'd lose so much more
than 20 percent on each house
because things like that just
hadn't happened before.
And so it seemed like they were
incredibly safe.
So that was the structure.
And the idea,
again, was to take risky
securities and by securitizing
them create a whole bunch of
apparently perfectly safe
securities.
Because, as we said,
the goal of most investors is
to invest in something that's
completely safe,
they don't have to worry about
getting more in one state or
more in another state.
And this seemed like an
ingenious way of turning 1
trillion dollars of very risky
sub-prime loans into,
this is 81 percent,
into 800 billion of very safe
bonds and maybe riskier bonds
down below that.
So you could never find 1
trillion dollars worth of people
willing to lend to sub-prime
borrowers,
but you didn't have to after
the securitization,
because 800 billion of the
loans to them were by people who
thought they were perfectly
safe.
You only had the guys buying
these bonds down here who
thought that they were running a
very big risk.
So the whole idea of
securitization,
the whole idea of the American
financial system was to--
well, let's see what the whole
idea was,
was to create as many safe
loans as possible.
So you could put it a little
bit more generally.
I should have had this picture
before.
You could say if the states of
the world--
if you're here today and you
might have many of these
different states of the world
tomorrow,
some people know that they're
going to be rich in some states
and poor in other states.
What they'd like to do is get
the same amount in every state.
They can do that by directly
buying safe bonds.
That's what everybody's trying
to do.
They're trying to hedge
themselves to get completely
safe bonds.
Most people don't know how to
hedge so the financial system
creates safe bonds for them.
Other people,
they do know how to hedge,
but their cash flows are
different in the different
states because,
for example,
they run a business and if
interest rates go up that might
be bad for their business.
If interest rates go down it
might be good for their
business, so they've got
different amounts of money in
the different states.
And then to create hedging
instruments for these people
you'd like to create securities
that pay a lot in states where
they want the money so that way
they can buy hedging
instruments.
So the purpose of the financial
system is to create cash flows
in states that people want them.
For the majority of people
that's the same thing in every
state.
For other people it's something
like the Arrow securities.
So they can buy money in the
states when they're running
short.
And why is this connected to
mortgages,
because how do you know that
anyone's going to keep their
promise to deliver money in
those different states,
or money in every state,
how do you know the people
making the promise will keep
their promise?
Well, you don't.
That's why you need collateral,
and the best collateral in the
country is the houses.
So the purpose of the financial
system,
as we said all through the
course, is to create securities
that pay off in different states
of nature,
of the type people want,
and that are guaranteed,
so that people keep their
promises,
guaranteed by collateral.
Houses as the best collateral
made it inevitable that the most
sophisticated part of the market
was going to turn into the
mortgage market.
So at first glance you would
think the most complicated part
of the market is the stock
market, but no.
It turns out that collateral is
the key,
because without guaranteeing a
promise the promise isn't really
very good,
and so houses are the best
collateral.
So we'll see now that the
change in the theory that I want
to describe is what happens when
you suppose people might break
their promises and you have to
take into account collateral.
All right, but let's get back
to the facts.
So there were 1 trillion
dollars of these sub-prime
mortgages around.
So then what happened?
I want to skip through this
pretty quickly.
People thought that it might be
dangerous and they wrote
insurance on the sub-prime
mortgages.
So an insurance on a sub-prime
mortgage,
CDS, Credit Default Swap,
would say if 1 dollar of the
principal of the triple-B bond
disappears,
and we saw how that could
happen, you take one homeowner
who loses 20 cents,
I mean, that will come out of
this first,
but after all this stuff is
wiped out,
20 cents of the losses because
the homeowner instead of paying
his dollar doesn't pay it all.
The house is sold.
You only get 80 cents back,
that 20 cents comes out of the
triple-B,
so the insurance would then
say--the buyer of insurance
would get to collect the 20
cents.
So this seemed like another way
for people even in the BBB range
to guarantee their payments.
Well, it turned out that the
writers of insurance didn't just
write 20 cents in case there was
a 20 cent loss,
they might write 10 dollars of
insurance on the 20 cent loss.
So these Credit Default Swaps
are getting very close to Arrow
securities.
So the theoretically inclined
economists who didn't think very
far ahead in the Clinton
Administration,
namely Larry Summers and people
like that,
Bob Rubin, they were ecstatic
about these Credit Default Swaps
because to them it reminded them
of Arrow securities.
And they thought,
my gosh, the market is coming
close to creating Arrow
securities and isn't it great
that people will now be able to
hedge much better because
they've got these Arrow
securities that they can trade.
Now, problem was that who's
writing the insurance?
The people writing the
insurance are big banks and
people like AIG.
So they're saying if you lose
20 cents we'll pay the
insurance.
Now, of course,
that's a promise just like the
promise to repay is and that
should have been collateralized.
The trouble is that when AIG as
a triple-A rated company wrote
its promises many of the people
who bought the insurance just
figured that's such a great
company it's obviously going to
have the money,
probably isn't going to happen
anyway,
so I'm not going to worry about
the collateral,
and they managed to make all of
these promises without putting
up collateral to guarantee that
they are going to keep their
promises.
This mistake that people make,
"Well,
it's probably not going to
happen anyway that we're going
to even collect the
insurance,"
you shouldn't have bought the
insurance if you didn't think
you were going to collect it.
So obviously,
even though it's a low
probability event,
you have to think what will
happen when it comes time to
collect the insurance.
Are they going to have the
money?
Now, many banks in Europe
bought these things and they are
accused of having realized that
they wouldn't be paid off.
They only bought it so they
could convince their regulators
that they actually had a very
sound bank and therefore didn't
have to set aside capital,
and they knew very well that
they probably wouldn't be paid
off.
They just didn't think that it
mattered because things wouldn't
go that bad.
So in any case,
to circle back,
we've got these sub-prime
mortgages where you've written a
bunch of apparently safe bonds.
A lot of people,
but not many,
20 percent holding dangerous
bonds,
realizing that they're
dangerous, and you've got a
bunch of insurance written on
the dangerous bonds,
but of a much bigger,
five times as big as the amount
of dangerous bonds.
If something goes wrong with
that pool these bonds are going
to lose and then the writers of
insurance are also going to lose
a huge amount of money.
So what happened?
Well, on top of that there was
a CDO market where you took the
triple-B pieces and broke those
up like you did before into
bonds,
more triple-A's and so on.
So if something happened to
this original pool and a lot of
homes started defaulting that
would wipe out all the
triple-B's forcing all these
people to pay insurance.
And on top of that the CDO
market which is just the same
thing done again,
but using the triple-B's as
collateral,
all these things would get
wiped out including the
triple-A's here.
And then that wasn't enough.
Wall Street then wrote
CDO-squareds on the triple-B and
A pieces of the CDOs.
All right, so we talked all
about this last time.
So now I want to get into what
happened.
Any questions?
Yes?
Student: So when these
were being securitized like the
triple-A is there any way to
distinguish on paper the normal
triple-A's and the triple-A's
derived from like triple-B's,
for example,
or are all triple-A's just the
same and there is no way to
distinguish them?
Prof: No,
a buyer knows very well where
his triple-A is coming from.
A buyer has access to all--so
if you were a buyer--
the hedge fund I work with,
Ellington,
was a big buyer of these kinds
of things,
and also you'll see what our
strategy was,
but we knew very well that--so
let's go back to this.
We were a big buyer of things
here, like these triple-B's we
bought a lot of.
So we could get for every
single home in this pool we knew
the history,
we know the loan to value,
the income of the borrower,
what zip code the borrower
lives in.
We know a tremendous amount of
information about each one of
these individual houses,
how they've paid before,
what kind of credit rating they
have.
All that information we have,
and so we build the model of
how reliable we think these
borrowers are and what they're
going to do.
And so on the basis of that
information we can predict what
we think the value of the BBB is
going to be,
and whether it makes sense to
buy insurance on it or not.
So what was our strategy,
by the way, in our hedge fund?
Our strategy was,
take a pool where we think that
the pool is really a good pool,
buy the riskiest piece which is
down here,
the residual that I described
last time,
for which there is no insurance.
Now, it may be that the whole
world goes to hell and we lose
money on our residual,
but so how do we hedge that?
What we do is then we take what
we think is a bad pool of loans,
they're from a county that we
think people aren't as reliable,
say, and we don't buy the
residual.
In fact, we do the opposite.
We buy the insurance on the
triple-B.
There is no insurance on the
residual.
So for the bad pool we've
bought the insurance.
For the good pool we've bought
the residual,
and so if we're right the
residual is going to pay a lot
of money because these people
aren't going to default.
And if the bad pool is as bad
as we think they're going to
default and we're going to
collect the insurance.
So we're going to win on both,
and if the whole market
collapses,
well, our residual will go to
zero,
but so will the BBB in the bad
pool and we'll collect insurance
and so we'll be protected.
So that was our strategy.
So, yes, the answer is you have
a lot of information about what
you're buying.
Student: It's not
actually a triple-A,
it's a triple-A of a bad pool.
Prof: Yeah,
this appears the triple-A of a
bad pool, but the people buying
the triple-A know exactly what's
in the pool.
Now, they may be dumb and not
bother to think about it and
just trust the triple-A rating
without thinking about it,
but probably a lot of them did
think about it.
And if we take this pool,
the CDO, these triple-A's were
held mostly by big banks,
and you would have thought they
were the most sophisticated of
all the buyers because they're
the ones creating the pools.
So they certainly know what's
in the pools.
They're the ones who created
this original pool here.
They're the ones who underwrote
those loans and so they're the
ones,
they know everything about it,
and they're the ones holding
all these triple-A's.
So we're not talking about
people who have no idea what
they're doing.
We're talking about people who
supposedly do know what they're
doing.
All right, so that was the
basis of the market.
Now, what happened?
So I can describe our hedging
strategy and our models,
but I'm not going to do that.
So this was our strategy.
You go long the residuals short
the bad pool.
Now, what happened?
Here's what happened.
There was an index that was
created in the beginning of
2006.
You just put together a huge
number of triple-B bonds and
triple-A bonds of different
pools and average their prices.
That's the index,
and so they're all 100,
you see?
And then in January of 2007 all
of a sudden the market starts to
go crazy, and by March and April
it's collapsed.
These bonds,
a lot of them,
the triple-B's,
have collapsed from 100,
where everything was,
all the way down to 60,
just like that.
In a few months it went from
100 to 60,100 here,
three or four months later it's
60.
This is March of 2007.
Now, what was the stock market
doing then?
You might remember the stock
market, S&P,
so here's the stock market,
too far in historical time,
but anyway, here's the stock
market.
It had this NASDAQ collapse,
but this point right here is
October 31st,
2007.
So ten months or nine months
later the stock market reaches
its peak.
So all this time from here up
the stock market is climbing and
climbing and climbing.
So the sub-prime mortgage
market has collapsed,
but clearly the rest of the
population doesn't think that
things are that bad.
So just to put everything in
perspective, where else are we?
What other big--housing,
let's look at housing prices
here.
We're going to come back to
this graph if you can see it.
So this is 2000 here.
This is 2009 here.
Green is the housing.
This is Shiller's housing index.
So if you set it at 100 in
2000, up here at the very top,
that's the middle of 2006,
it hit its peak and then
started to come.
So housing hit its peak in the
middle of 2006,
the third quarter of 2006,
and then sort of didn't come
down very fast,
but started to come down.
Sub-prime mortgages collapsed
in January of 2007 and the stock
market started its very quick
collapse in October-November of
2007.
So it was first housing prices
turned,
then sub-prime mortgages
collapsed,
then the stock market ten
months later collapsed,
so we have to explain all of
these things and what was going
on.
So in the--sorry, where was I?
So this is the sub-prime market
collapsing.
Why did this market collapse?
What happened to make them
collapse?
This is actually an example of
the wonderful nature of the
American financial system.
The fact the market collapsed
is a great thing because why did
it collapse,
what was the information that
made people think that things
were going to go down?
Well, it was this information,
cumulative loss by reporting
month.
Let's look at some.
These are Countrywide,
they're one of the bad guys,
that is they're one of the ones
whose loans went bad and the
company went out of business,
basically, and got bought by
Bank of America.
So look at delinquencies
historically.
So for 2003,
these are Countrywide loans
given in 2003.
It's the brown thing.
So here are their
delinquencies,
right?
They start at 0,
naturally and then they go up
to 2 percent and they stay there
as a function of the pool.
Some of those guys are
defaulting and being thrown out
of the pool.
That's how delinquencies can go
down.
Also people can start paying
after being delinquent.
Delinquent just means you're
missing some payments.
Look at 2004.
They're still hardly doing
anything.
And then look at 2005.
Well, all of a sudden
delinquencies start going up.
In 2005--they're 5 percent by
the end of 2007,
but delinquencies,
5 percent delinquencies.
We're just talking about people
who missed a few payments,
5 percent delinquencies.
They haven't actually been
thrown out of their house.
It takes 18 months.
Nobody's lost anything.
They've just been delinquent
for a little while.
So what was the catastrophe
that made the market collapse?
Well, this is it.
So WALA means Weighted Average
Age.
So look at the months.
So you take things that were
issued in--this is the
securitization.
They're bundled together in the
beginning of 2006.
This is the second half of
2006, but the loans actually
started in 2005 they just didn't
get--the homeowners got their
mortgages in 2005.
They got securitized in 2006.
So you look at the
delinquencies and you see that
nothing happens the first 12
months, these are losses,
and then eventually it goes it
1 percent.
The losses go to 1 percent.
We're not talking about giant
numbers.
Well, everybody saw that.
Then they looked at the losses
for things issued second half of
2006,
and the losses,
that's this blue line,
they are going to,
we're talking about 20 months
later,
they're going to 1 percent or
1.2 percent.
You look at the things issued
in 2007, which means that the
loans you're really measuring
from somewhere in the middle of
2006.
At 1 year you're at half a
percent.
And in the second half of 2007
you're at .2 percent losses,
so no losses at all.
So nothing horrible has
happened except for the fact
there's an obvious pattern here.
It seems like every newer
vintage is getting worse,
and worse, and worse,
and worse.
And so it was on that basis,
just seeing things getting
worse before there were any
losses.
Remember, these are very
sophisticated people betting
hundreds of millions of dollars.
They're thinking hard about
this.
Even though nothing had
happened yet the market
collapsed.
So this collapse that happens
here is before anybody has lost
any money.
Hardly anyone's been thrown out
of their house.
Nothing's happened in the
economy,
but the traders have already
figured out things are on a bad
course,
things are going to look really
bad and the market collapsed.
So we had warning.
This is the beginning of 2007.
We're almost at the end of
2009, so it was almost three
years ago.
Nearly three years ago
everybody should have known that
the market had figured out that
there was going to be a
catastrophe in the sub-prime
world,
a real catastrophe because the
losses were going to be 40
percent.
That's what they were expecting.
You can't have losses like that
unless you throw out,
you know, it's a huge number of
people that have to get thrown
out of their houses,
and you have to lose a huge
amount of money on each house in
order to get losses of 40
percent.
Like I said,
if you lose 50 percent on every
loan you have to throw 80
percent of the people out of
their houses to get 40 percent
losses.
So this meant that people were
expecting gigantic catastrophe.
By the way, that was an
exaggeration because this is the
triple-B piece.
I meant the triple-B piece was
going to lose 40 percent.
So the triple-B piece is only
protected by 6 or 8 percent so
it means the total losses would
be 10 percent,
10 or 15 percent,
which means if you're losing 50
percent on a house 30 percent of
the people are going to be
thrown out of their houses.
So it's like 30 percent losses
and 30 percent of the people
thrown out of their houses.
That was the expectation then,
but that's still terrible.
There were five million
sub-prime people,
so the market at this point is
expecting 30 percent of them to
be thrown out of their houses
with 30 percent losses even
though the losses are 1 percent
or less.
So you can see how far sighted
the market is.
So our government,
everybody should have been
warned right at this point that
something was going to happen.
Now, did the stock market
realize this was such a
catastrophe,
absolutely not because the
stock market waited until the
end of 2007,
which we're talking about here,
and now look at where the
losses are in sub-prime bonds.
Here the stock market started
to go down.
So it had all this warning that
something horrible was happening
in the mortgage market,
but the stock market owners
thought nothing of it.
They thought,
"Well, how could this
possibly affect us?"
And only here do they start to
catch on.
So to give you an example of
the losses, this is only up to
December 2007,
people kept announcing losses.
Merrill announced 9 billion.
Citi Corp announced 10 billion
and then the next week another
10 billion.
UBS announced 3.7 billion and
then another 10 billion.
Goldman announced 5 billion,
Morgan Stanley 4 billion.
Every other day someone was
coming out saying that they had
lost all these billions.
And that was only in December
2007.
The losses accelerated like
crazy through 2008,
so there were hundreds of
billions of dollars lost.
Now, the whole sub-prime market
is only 1 trillion,
but remember there was all that
insurance written on it.
And who was writing the
insurance?
These very same people were the
ones writing the insurance.
So you not only lost the
hundreds of billions in the
sub-prime market,
but also multiply that by 5,
the hundreds of billions all
these guys wrote in insurance
and in CDO triple-A's that they
held.
So, all right,
now let's say one other fact
that's quite interesting.
These are prepayments.
So I told you that in sub-prime
loans for the first two years,
the sub-prime loan,
you'd be locked into the loan.
A huge penalty if you prepaid,
but between year two and year
three you could prepay,
get a new loan,
refinance it and then in year
three the interest rate would
jump.
So what would people do?
Well, people who made all their
payments the first two years
would be regarded as reliable
payers and so of course they
would refinance.
They'd no longer be such
sub-prime people.
They'd refinance into loans
with lower interest because
they'd be regarded as better
credit risks.
So if you go back to 2003 you
see that after the second year
prepayments go up to 70 percent.
So 70 percent of the people
would refinance their loan
between year two and three.
In 2004, that's the pink one,
the same thing happened,
60 or 70 percent of all those
people over the course of a year
refinanced their loans.
So that means that the original
lenders got 70 percent of the
money back.
It's like a prepayment like we
have in mortgages.
Well, in sub-prime these guys
had a huge incentive to do it
once they proved that they were
good people.
And as I told you,
most of the sub-prime borrowers
are young people who had screwed
up with their credit cards and
things like that,
and after they paid for a while
people would realize that they'd
settled down and give them a new
loan,
but look what's happened to
these numbers,
so if you jump to 2007 all
these things just collapsed,
no more prepayments,
and once there are no more
prepayments that means the
lenders don't get their 70
percent back.
So if you're a hedge fund
figuring,
"How much can I lose if I
buy one of these sub-prime
things,"
you know that between year two
and year three you're going to
get 70 percent of your money
back so you can't lose more than
30 percent.
All of a sudden you're getting
10 percent of your money back
which means you could lose 90
percent.
So, why would that have
happened?
Well, we're going to come to
that.
So those are the basic facts.
I don't have time to say more
than that, so any questions
about those basic facts?
Now we need something to
explain how they happened.
Yes?
Student: So ultimately
the slope of the line is getting
steeper, is that what you're
saying, so the projected loss
percentage, right?
Prof: Exactly.
So people were realizing--yeah,
that was all that it was.
People just said to themselves
every--
that's exactly what I'm saying
that people said,
"Look, we know that losses
are going to increase,
but they're probably not going
to get very far.
Historically they get to 3
percent or 4 percent or
something like that.
That's it.
That's all we have to worry
about.
And it's early on,
so it's not like we've seen any
losses, but they just seem to be
happening so much faster than
they did before.
Let's extrapolate that
curve."
Now, how do you extrapolate a
curve like that?
There are so many ways you
could extrapolate it.
So the market extrapolated and
thought, "Gosh,
things are getting just much
worse," and the market
started to collapse.
So you see, in real trading
markets people respond very
quickly to very little
information.
I mean, their whole livelihood
depends on it.
It's all they're thinking about
and so they're coming up with
quick conclusions,
which in this case like in many
others, they're not so crazy.
They're realizing something bad
is happening and they're acting
very quickly,
and so huge--billions of
dollars are being lost just on
the basis of this amount of
evidence.
I think this brings home how
fast the market acts and how
expectations about the future
are driving prices,
and therefore how much
information--
you remember,
we said that if you just pay
attention to the market you can
learn a lot.
Well, we didn't learn that
much, the whole stock market.
They weren't paying attention
to what was happen.
The mortgage market was
collapsing.
That should have meant
something, but they weren't
paying attention to it.
Nothing in the world seemed to
change because there were no
people on the streets yet.
Now there are people
unemployed, there are people on
the streets,
there are going to be millions
of guys on the streets pretty
soon,
homeowners on the streets.
And of course so now the stock
market has caught on that things
are really bad.
All right, so any more
questions about this?
So now I want to talk about a
way of understanding what
happened, and then I'm going to
end.
So I'm going to go from more
general to more specific.
So I'm going to talk about a
way of understanding what
happened and then we're going to
talk concretely about how you
would change the mathematics
we've been doing all semester.
So my view of all this is that
it's the leverage cycle,
which is--the leverage cycle,
as I'll define it in a second,
has to do with putting up
collateral to make sure you're
going to pay,
and so far in the course we've
paid no attention to that,
and in all of economic theory
they never paid attention to
that.
You can read anyone of those
textbooks that were on the
reading list by all of the great
Nobel Prize winners,
and all the great financial
economists,
and you'll never see the word,
hardly ever see the word
collateral,
and you'll never see,
what's the equilibrium amount
of collateral?
And so that's been entirely
missing.
So, in fact,
if you think about
macroeconomics and the Fed they
always tell you that if things
go bad in the economy reduce the
interest rate.
That's the way we can stimulate
investment.
We can raise the price of
assets by lowering the interest
rate.
If we raise the interest rate
we'll lower the price of assets.
We can always get the economy
to boom or slow down by
adjusting the interest rate.
The most important thing ever
done in macroeconomics in theory
and practice is to establish the
Federal Reserve and give it the
responsibility of managing
interest rates.
Now, in my view it should be
managing collateral rates and
not interest rates.
And in fact it has the power to
manage,
it's been given the authority
to manage collateral rates when
it was created,
but it just never exercises
that authority.
Now, as I said in class,
Shakespeare already had this
idea.
In The Merchant of
Venice,
as we said, they were haggling
over the interest rate and not
just over collateral and
Shakespeare anticipated the
impatience theory of interest
and Shylock,
who you know,
the modern reading of The
Merchant of Venice is that
it's about anti-Semitism and
Shylock is supposed to be a bad
guy.
I don't think Shakespeare
intended that at all.
In fact, Shylock is much more
sophisticated,
by far, and much better
understanding of what's going on
in the world than either
Antonio--
well, certainly than Antonio
who is the merchant of Venice
and Bassanio's actually,
I think, quite clever,
although Harold Bloom makes
Bassanio out to be an idiot and
a dupe,
and can't imagine how Portia
could possibly marry such a guy.
But anyway, I think that
Bassanio is a very attractive
guy and I think that Shylock,
he's the only one who really
understands what's going on.
So he explains the entire
modern theory of impatience to
Bassanio and Antonio and says
that's why the interest rate
should be high.
And then they haggle over the
collateral.
And of course,
Shakespeare,
in my view,
thought the collateral was much
more important than the interest
because nobody can remember the
rate of interest they agreed on,
but everybody remembers the
pound of flesh collateral.
And remember that the play ends
with the ships all sinking,
apparently, and so should
Shylock take his collateral or
not,
and the court rules not that
you should reduce the collateral
or you shouldn't take the
collateral but you should have a
different collateral.
It should have been a pound of
flesh, but not a drop of blood.
So it's the responsibility of
the judicial system and the
regulatory body to monitor not
the interest rate,
not the amount of the
borrowing, but the collateral
that's put up for it.
And that's exactly what my
message is going to be.
We have to manage the
collateral.
And so I wrote about this
starting in 1997,
and 2003, and then again in
2008, and I've written with a
bunch of people,
and I have students who wrote
on it.
And Araujo and Pascoa were two
Brazilians who wrote about it.
I gave a talk there in 1997.
I got them going on it.
And then Bernanke himself wrote
about collateral in the '90s at
the same time,
even earlier than I was,
but he didn't have the idea of
leverage and collateral rate.
He knew that you needed
collateral.
He talked about collateral,
but he didn't talk about the
ratio and the rate.
So what do I mean by that?
If you have a house that's
worth 100 dollars,
say, it's collateral for a loan
because if you don't pay the
loan they can take your house.
So that's called no recourse
collateral if they take your
house, but they can't go after
you for anything more.
Now that, in fact,
is not by law what happens,
but in practice what happens.
If you default on your mortgage
they'll take your house,
but they aren't going to come
after you to try and get your
income or something like that.
So it's as if all they can do
is take your house.
In some states explicitly by
law they can only take your
house.
In other states you still owe
the money, but they always just
say, "Forget about it.
We're just taking your
house."
So I'm going to assume that
they take your house and no
more.
If the house is worth 100
dollars and you borrow 80 then
the collateral rate is 125
percent,
because a 100 dollar house is
protecting an 80 dollar loan,
so it's 125 percent.
The loan to value,
it's an 80 dollar loan on a 100
dollar house,
is 80 percent.
The margin is the margin of
safety,
it's a 100 dollar house so the
lender thinks that he's
protected because he's holding a
100 dollar house and he only
gave you 20 dollars.
So it's 20 percent and the
leverage is 5 because with 20
dollars of cash you've managed
to buy a house worth 5 times as
much, 100.
So these numbers are all the
same thing.
It's just different ways of
saying the same thing.
So I prefer leverage,
but collateral rate,
they're all the same thing.
Student: Could you
explain what the 5 is?
Prof: 5 is a 100 dollar
house and you only paid 20
dollars.
You borrowed the other 80.
So with 20 dollars of cash you
can manage to own a 100 dollar
asset, so the leverage is 5.
So people who borrow a lot can
own huge quantities of things
even though they had hardly any
money.
So, as I say,
when you're negotiating the
loan you have to negotiate the
interest rate,
but you also have to negotiate
the leverage.
How much cash do you have to
put down in order to get the
house?
How much can you borrow using
the house as collateral?
Now, in the standard theory
that Fisher taught that we've
described in this class,
you've got supply and demand
determining the interest rate.
Leverage never appeared.
We just always assumed everyone
was going to repay their loan.
So in my theory supply and
demand are going to determine
both the interest rate and the
leverage.
Now that seems a little
shocking because how can one
equation determine two
variables?
So I think it's for this reason
that economists,
basically all these years,
ignored leverage because they
just didn't see any way to fit
two variables with one equation
and solve for two variables.
So they just said,
"Well, for simplicity
we'll assume everyone always
repays."
Now, what is it that's going to
determine leverage?
Well, this is common sense as
Fisher and Shakespeare before
him said that interest rates are
determined by impatience.
In my view leverage,
there are many determinants,
but the most important
determinant is volatility,
the volatility of the asset
price.
Why is that?
Because you've got a house of
100 protecting the 80 dollar
loan,
if you think the housing price
is going up and down and it
might fall below 80 then you're
not going to feel very safe.
If you think the housing price
is rock solid at 100 you're
going to feel very safe and
you'll even loan more than 80.
So the volatility of the
housing price,
obviously, is what controls how
safe the lender feels,
and so volatility has got to be
the most important determinant
of leverage,
but it's hard to see how to fit
that into a supply and demand
equation.
So the theory,
my theory, is going to be that
the higher the leverage is,
which supply and demand is
going to determine,
the higher the asset prices
are, and the lower leverage is
the lower the asset prices are.
Now, why should this be the
case?
Well, in my view there are many
different potential buyers,
let's say a continuum of
potential buyers and each of
them has a different view of
what the asset is worth,
and so you have this continuum.
Now, let's, for simplicity
even, suppose that everyone has
a number in his head about what
the asset's worth.
That's what we did on the very
first day.
Everyone had a reservation
price of the asset.
And let's say,
though, that they're willing to
buy more than one football
ticket.
They're willing to buy as many
football tickets as they can get
as long as the price is less
than the reservation price.
So what happens,
the people who have the highest
valuation naturally are going to
buy the assets,
and the people with low
valuations are going to sell
them,
and somewhere there will be a
marginal guy.
So people above here are going
to be the buyers,
and people below here are going
to be the sellers.
And what's the price going to
be?
It's going to be the valuation
of this marginal guy.
He's marginal precisely because
he's indifferent between being a
buyer or a seller which means
the price for him is just right.
These guys up here think the
price is too low.
That's why they're buyers.
These guys down here think the
price is too high.
That's why they're sellers.
So this is all consistent with
what we saw in the football
ticket example.
Now, one little twist is where
does this have to be?
Well, it depends on how much
money these guys up here have.
So Fisher actually said this.
If you make people who really
like to consume now richer
you're going to get a different
interest rate,
or if you make the patient
people richer you'll have a
lower interest rate.
Well, the same logic here.
If you make the natural buyers
richer you're not going to need
as many of them to buy the
assets and the marginal guy will
go up here and the price will
rise,
not because the payoffs of the
asset have changed,
but because the marginal buyer
has gone up.
So to put it another way,
a more important way,
if it's easier to borrow
because leverage is higher,
so you can buy that 100 dollar
house with only 10 dollars down
instead of 20 dollars down,
then each of these natural
buyers instead of being able to
afford to buy one house can buy
two houses or two mortgage
securities,
or buy a house that's twice as
big.
So the natural buyers,
with a lot of leverage,
a few of them will be able to
buy all the assets,
and the marginal buyer will be
very high and the price will be
very high.
If there's no leverage and no
borrowing it's going to take a
lot of them to buy all the
assets,
and the marginal buyer will be
down here and the price will be
very low.
So leverage is clearly going to
affect the price.
And notice how shocking this is.
What would Fisher say about
this?
So this sounds like such common
sense, how could this be wrong?
It sounds like it's so obvious.
But now, why didn't anybody say
this before?
Why didn't Fisher say this?
Because remember what Fisher
said.
He said the price of every
asset is the fundamental value
of the cash flows.
You take the future cash flows
and you discount them by the
interest rate,
say, and that's what the price
is.
I'm saying, even if the
interest rate doesn't change,
you just change the amount of
leverage so these natural buyers
at the top,
fewer of them are going to be
able to buy all the assets,
then that's going to make the
price higher.
So the price is not going to be
equal to the fundamental value.
In fact, there isn't a
fundamental value.
It all depends on the different
opinions of the different
people.
So what are the reasons they
differ?
Why should there be people who
disagree about what the value
is?
I think that there are
basically four reasons,
or five reasons.
Four of them,
anyway, are one,
these people,
let's say, are more risk
tolerant than the people down
here.
So the people down here are so
scared to hold these assets
because they might pay low
numbers,
low payoffs in some states and
high payoffs in other states.
So that assumes that they can't
insure themselves against
everything.
So that's another crucial
ingredient to my theory which
I'm not going,
you know, in the background
here is the idea there's not
insurance for everything.
So the asset here is going to
be regarded as risky if it pays
less in some states than other.
So because some people are less
risk averse, they're more risk
tolerant, they're going to be
willing to pay more for the
asset.
That's one reason.
Another reason is these people
might just be more optimistic
than these people.
So far we've assumed that
everybody believed in the same
probabilities.
What if these guys' probability
of the up state is always higher
than these guys' probability of
the up state?
Then they're going to be
willing to pay more than these
guys are.
Another reason might be these
people simply like the asset.
They like living in the house.
These people are the New York
bankers.
They're just lending money.
They couldn't care less about
living in the house.
The house to them is just a
source of income.
For these people,
they really want to live in the
house.
So another thing could be some
people just have more expertise.
They know how to read all these
statements of loans.
They can analyze the loan level
data,
and these people don't have the
time,
or it gives them a headache,
or they don't know how to find
the loan level data to go
through,
house by house,
who the homeowners are and how
reliable they are,
so naturally they're going to
be scared of buying because
they're going to figure these
guys know more than they do.
So these are all different
reasons why some people would be
willing to pay more than other
people.
And so therefore,
and as I say,
in the standard theory the
asset price is supposed to be
the fundamental value.
We don't talk very much about
the heterogeneity of the people
and how that makes the
definition of fundamental value
hard to maintain.
So in my theory,
in short, in equilibrium in
normal times or good times
there's going to be too much
leverage and therefore too high
asset prices,
and in bad times there's going
to be too little leverage and
therefore too low asset prices,
and this recurs over and over
again,
and it's what I call the
Leverage Cycle,
what I called the Leverage
Cycle.
Now, let me give you an example
of what people really had to pay
for these things.
So for a bank buying a triple-A
security there's regulation
which forces them to put a
certain amount of cash down.
So they have their depositors'
money, so they can buy things
with depositors' money,
but they have to put some of
their own capital down.
So how much do they have to put
down?
1.6 percent,
so they could leverage 60 to 1,
a 100 dollar asset,
they only paid 1.6 dollars in
cash.
If you look at all the so
called toxic mortgage securities
of which there were 2 and 1 half
trillion,
these are the things that
crushed all the banks that they
held,
I went through security by
security and made a guess as to
how much cash was put down by
the buyer of each of those
securities and on average I
got--
so this is not absolutely
accurate,
there are a lot of guesses,
but I got 16 to 1 as the
leverage.
So that meant that,
if that number's right,
it means 150 billion dollars of
cash was paid,
and 2.35 trillion was borrowed.
That's 16 to 1 leverage.
So that means that,
you know, think about it,
Bill Gates and Warren Buffett,
two people by themselves,
in 2006 had almost 150 billion
dollars.
So that means two guys in the
whole economy could have bought
every single toxic mortgage
security because they could have
borrowed the rest of the money
they needed to buy.
So when you think of where this
line is what I'm saying is that
for all the mortgage securities,
all the toxic mortgage
securities, sub-prime,
all those supposedly dangerous
securities you could have had
the marginal buyer way up here.
That's all that was required.
Those are the only number of
people,
this top little echelon of
people bought all those
securities,
could have bought all those
securities because they had
enough money to do it,
and they hardly had to put
anything down.
All right, the same was true
with housing.
Now, let's look at this theory
a little bit.
So I should have--sorry,
I could have put this in a
better thing.
So I give all these talks with
Shiller for alumni during the
crisis.
We haven't given one in a
while, but there was,
you know, lots of them.
Like every month or two months
we'd be giving one of these
talks and they'd bring in all
these donors to say,
"Yale needs your money
now," and they'd say,
"We don't have any money.
So anyhow, I'm just joking.
So we'd have a lot of these
talks and Shiller would always
put up the green graph.
So on the right hand side,
I showed you this before,
it's his famous diagram.
He did a brilliant thing.
He decided to collect data on
every transaction.
Every time someone purchased a
house he'd keep track of it,
because it's all public
information,
and then he'd compare it to the
same house that was sold before,
and do a few other tricks that
I don't have time to explain,
to make an index of the housing
prices in the whole country.
And so he'd done this going
back many years,
but starting in 2000 the thing
that he called attention to
before anybody,
he said, "Look at this.
Look at this line.
The housing price index from
2000 to 2006 it's gone up by
almost 100 percent."
The housing index was 100 in
2000 when it started,
that's 110, sorry.
This is 100.
It was 100 when it started here
in 2000 and it goes up to 190 in
2006.
That's 90 percent in 6 years.
To almost double in six years
that means it's gone up 12
percent a year or something.
So a staggering increase in the
price of housing,
and then it started to go down.
So he called attention to this
already as it was coming up.
So in 2004 and 2005 he was
saying, "My gosh,
there's a bubble.
It's going crazy,"
and he'd say,
"Everybody is nuts.
Americans, there's irrational
exuberance and people are so
crazy that they just think
things are always going to go up
and the price is going up higher
and higher and higher."
And then when it got so high
the narrative changed.
People started getting worried
and they started telling
everyone the world was coming to
an end and the prices went down,
and down, and down because we
have irrational exuberance.
And things are picking up a
little bit,
but we don't know whether
people are irrationally
exuberant,
or pessimistic,
or they're blipping,
but anyway, they're irrational.
So that's a story that has a
certain compelling nature to it
and he deserves a lot of credit
for calling attention to it.
But in my story I say these
prices are related to leverage.
So I went through every loan,
loan by loan,
that wasn't a government loan.
So these are private loans.
You can't get the data on
government loans.
So on private loans you know
every time someone took out a
mortgage they were selling the
loan, so therefore they
published the data.
You know what the appraised
value of the house was or the
sale price if they were buying
it for the first time,
and you know what all the loans
are.
So I added up the value of all
the loans and I divided it by
the price of the house,
and I subtracted it off to get
what the down payment was,
the cash down payment,
so this is 2 percent down,
4 percent down,
6 percent down,
or if you take 100 percent
minus this,
this is the loan to value,
so this is 100 percent.
You've borrowed everything.
Here you borrowed 98 percent of
the value, 96 percent of the
house, 94 percent of the house,
etcetera.
So in 2000 these are slightly
riskier people.
Amazingly they're putting down
14 percent, not amazingly.
They're putting down 14 percent
so it's 7 to 1 leverage.
But then look what happened.
The leverage went up,
and up, and up,
and up, and then it was,
in 2006, less than 3 percent
down.
These people were 30 to 1
leveraged.
I said the securities market
was 16 to 1 leveraged,
the triple-A part 60 to 1
leveraged.
Here they're 30 to 1 leveraged
and so the prices went up.
But yes the prices went up
because the leverage went up.
You hardly had to put any money
down.
That's why people were willing
to buy such expensive houses
because they weren't actually
putting that much money down.
And then leverage collapsed
like this and you had to put
more and more money down,
and then the whole market,
you know,
you can't get a loan basically
anymore unless you're getting a
government loan.
And so leverage collapsed and
the housing prices went down.
Leverage was collapsing faster
and in front of housing prices.
So I think it's the leverage
which is a crucial determinant
of the price,
and not irrational exuberance,
although I think there is
irrational exuberance,
but I think leverage is what's
underneath it and more basic.
Now, let's do the same thing
with prices.
So we did the sub-prime index
before.
This red line is the prime
index.
So we're talking about not
sub-prime homeowners,
but prime, people with
brilliant credit ratings and
stuff.
So even now years,
three years after the crisis
has started,
the losses on these pools are
still in the single digits,
5 percent, 6 percent,
things like that and most of
these,
8 percent maybe,
and most of these,
these are the trip--the top
piece of a pool of prime
borrowers.
So most of these loans are,
they're protected by 8 percent
of the bottom piece.
So you have to go through 8
percent losses before you touch
them at all.
So it's just inconceivable that
you'd see 40 percent losses,
but so what happened?
These bonds were at 100.
This is 100 over here.
The price is 100.
They're at 100.
Now, the interest rate is
changing and the prices are
going up and down because
they're supposed to be floaters
which always pay more or less
depending on the interest rate.
So they should be locked in at
100, but they're not floating
exactly on the same time,
you know, they don't change
their float so fast.
So the price is going up and
down because of that,
but it's clear that nobody
thinks there are going to be any
losses.
And then all of a sudden in
2007, but later,
this is much later than the
sub-prime market collapse,
these prices collapse,
and they collapse all the way
to 60,
shocking.
It's just inconceivable,
I think, that people could have
thought there are going to be 40
percent losses,
or that everybody could have
thought there are going to be 40
percent losses,
and then they've shot back up
to 80.
So there's been a huge gain.
So if you look at a typical
hedge fund like Ellington you'll
see that we lost a lot of money,
and now we've made a huge
amount of money.
So that was not such brilliant
hedging, but anyway.
So, but now why did these
prices collapse and go back up?
Is it that people just got
totally irrationally pessimistic
and then they said,
"Oh, things can't really
be that bad,"
and things got better?
Well, let's look at the
leverage, what is the down
payment, the same thing as
before on triple-A securities.
Now amazingly the Fed has never
kept these numbers,
and they're still not keeping
these numbers.
So I testified in front of Ben
Bernanke and the Board of
Governors on October 2008.
There were several of us,
but it was for four and a half
hours.
And I showed them this graph.
So this graph is at my hedge
fund, Ellington--it's just a
bunch of securities that we're
used to trading.
It's how much they were
offering to lend us,
what the down payment was they
were insisting if we wanted to
leverage as much as we could.
So we didn't leverage anything
like that, but this is what they
were offering us on the kinds of
securities that we're interested
in.
So this is not the greatest
data because we're only looking
at what we're interested in,
and we're only looking at the
offers made to us.
So, but looked what happened.
In '98 when there was a
leverage crisis,
that was the last one,
I must have skipped a slide
where I said the last leverage
cycle ended in '98.
It was 10 percent down.
That means 10 to 1 leverage,
and then suddenly it went to 40
percent down.
So leverage drastically dropped.
The down payment,
the margin, radically increased
for a few months during the
crisis then it went back to 10
percent.
Then we had 10 percent down for
a long time.
That's 10 to 1 leverage.
And then for a couple of years
it became 5 to 1 leverage,
so 20 to 1,5 to 1,
sorry, 5 percent down means 20
to 1 leverage.
So the leverage had drastically
increased,
and then leverage suddenly
started collapsing and lenders
asked for more and more down
payments,
more and more down payments.
And leverage was just
collapsing, and it happened
ahead of the prices,
and then leverage actually
picked up here and went down
again.
Then--this graph is quite old
now, May.
I should have updated it.
Leverage has gone way up again
and the prices have gone way up.
So you see, leverage goes down
the prices go down.
Leverage goes up the prices go
up, and leverage is still
heading up and the prices are
much higher.
So that's my view.
It's leverage that's
determining a lot of these
things.
All right, and so as I said,
there's recurring leverage
cycles.
In 1998 there was a leverage
cycle.
That's when Long-Term
Capital--so there was a book on
the collapse of Long-Term
Capital that Lowenstein wrote
that's on the reading list.
Before that was Orange County.
You remember my firm Kidder
Peabody went out of business in
1994, the end of '94.
The beginning of '94,
Orange County got bankrupted
partly thanks to buying
securities from Kidder Peabody.
Some of you may live in Orange
County.
In any case that was the
derivatives crisis,
and in 1987 there was a stock
market crash,
so anyway, it's hard to
document all the historical
leverage cycles because the Fed
has never kept this data,
and most other firms don't keep
their historical data.
We at Ellington realized after
'98 that this was a huge
problem, leverage,
and so we kept all the
historical data.
That's when I wrote my first
paper on leverage and collateral
and that being a crucial
ingredient of the--
so we have this data and
practically nobody else has.
So for me the most important
thing,
the first step the Fed should
do is keep track of the leverage
that is being allowed for,
the margins that are being
demanded on every security,
housing and securities.
And I heard this talk,
I told you,
last night on the collapse of
the electric grid in 2003,
and so I said,
"What have you done?"
Obviously the obvious question
everyone wanted to know.
So, "What have you done to
make it safer?"
And they said the one thing
they did is now they've spent
tens and tens of millions of
dollars getting more data.
So they now monitor every
single power line in real time.
They had farmed that out to
other people before and they
weren't very careful about it.
Now they're incredibly careful
about monitoring every single
line.
So as soon as one line goes
down they switch the electricity
and they move it evenly across a
bunch of other lines.
In the old days when a power
line went down the grid
automatically--
sort of, electricity went,
the power went to the next
closest place and that would
overload the next closest one
and maybe make that one go down.
Now if they know it's gone down
they choose how to re-divide it.
But the point is,
you can't do all that without
information,
and they're spending tens of
millions of dollars monitoring
everything and we still are not
monitoring what leverage is.
I think it's a shocking thing.
We should be monitoring
leverage and then we should be
regulating it,
and instead we haven't even
begun to monitor it,
much less to figure out how to
regulate it.
Now, why was the leverage
cycle--I said,
this recurs over and over
again.
So why was the leverage cycle
so bad this time than it was
before?
So this is my short version.
I have a long version of this.
The short version is because
leverage got higher than it ever
did before,
and there are lots of reasons
why leverage got higher than it
ever did before.
We had this period of low
volatility for a long time,
so it made it higher.
We then had securitization
which we didn't have before.
So a sub-prime borrower would
have had to put down a huge down
payment in the old days,
because people would have
regarded it as such a risky
thing,
but once we packaged all the
sub-prime loans together in a
big security and the triple-A
guy got the best of the houses,
not each house,
not a share of every house,
but only a share of the very
best houses,
it all of a sudden became a
much safer loan and so you could
borrow a lot more money against
it,
against that triple-A loan.
So the triple-A piece,
using that as collateral,
you could borrow a lot of
money, a big percentage of the
price of the triple-A thing you
could borrow,
whereas if you had a single
sub-prime loan people would
never lend more than 50 percent
of the value of the house or
something.
The second reason why things
were so bad was because we had a
double leverage cycle.
We had leverage shooting
through the roof not just in
securities as it had before.
As I showed you in '98 where it
was at 10 percent down,
and then there was a collapse
to 40 percent down,
and then back to 10 percent
down, that was a big change,
in the crisis stage,
leverage collapse,
but here we had it in housing
as well where there was a
feedback between the two.
So why is it that all these
people stopped being able to
refinance their loans in 2007,
which contributed so much to
the losses?
It's not because the interest
rates were suddenly too high for
them.
Those didn't change at all.
It's that the lenders suddenly
demanded a much bigger down
payment.
Instead of 3 percent down they
had to put 25 percent down and
they couldn't afford to do it,
so they couldn't refinance
their loan.
They didn't have the cash,
so they were stuck with the old
loan, and so the original lender
was in much more jeopardy.
And then the last thing is the
CDS market.
So I have to explain this.
That's why it's going to spill
over into next time.
So these insurance things,
there are many ways of
interpreting what they did and
why they were so dangerous,
but one of them is that they
allowed people to write
insurance to lose huge amounts
of money.
So that's an obvious thing.
That's why the losses were so
big, but more interesting than
that,
they allowed the pessimists to
leverage themselves,
because in our old story from
way back here,
in this old story--where was
the old story with that?
In this story,
remember, I said that the
natural buyers,
you'd have fewer of them if
they could leverage a lot.
So what were these guys down
here doing?
Well, they couldn't do anything
except sell the assets and maybe
make the loans.
As the price got higher and
higher these guys down here,
presumably, were getting more
and more disgusted and thinking,
"Well, this market's
ridiculous,
and the price is way too high.
We don't want to buy here."
And I've talked to a lot of
insurance companies like
Northwestern Mutual Life,
the guy who runs that.
He said, "We used to be a
big buyer of mortgage securities
and sub-prime mortgages and
stuff in 2004,
and the price got so high in
2006 to us it became ridiculous
so we just dropped out of the
market."
But dropping out of the market
is one thing.
What if they could bet against
the market?
Well, they had no opportunity
to do that before.
They couldn't express their
negative view,
but starting in 2005 where this
CDS market really took off,
they could suddenly express
their negative view.
So in my view and in my opinion
what happened was that at end of
2005 the pessimists for the
first time were able to bet on
the market going down.
And so that's what started to
make prices go down,
because of the CDS market.
When prices started to go down
the mortgage securities that had
been sold with all that leverage
for high prices started to go
down in price.
That meant that new
securitizations weren't worth
it.
You couldn't make the profit
that we were talking about
before, putting all of these
things together and selling off
the bonds.
The bonds are being sold for a
lower price.
You couldn't lend all that
money to these people.
You were getting the money to
lend to the people by selling
the bonds.
If you sell the bonds at a
lower price you don't have the
money to lend to the people.
So in order to make the bonds
sell for a higher price they
demanded that the homeowners put
up more collateral,
and then that meant the
homeowners couldn't refinance,
and then that started to make
the world more dangerous,
and that's why,
then, on securities,
the lenders on securities
reduced the leverage and then
the whole thing started to
spiral.
That's my story of how the
things started.
So let's say that.
In the bottom of the leverage
cycle the same bad three things
always happen.
Number one there's scary bad
news that creates more
uncertainty and more
disagreement.
So it wasn't just that people
thought that losses were going
to go from 40 percent to 20
percent on sub-prime mortgages.
It's that they went from 4
percent expected,
with a range of 1 to 5 percent,
to 30 percent,
but maybe they'd be 80 percent,
the losses.
There was a huge
volatility--nobody really knew
what the hell was going to
happen.
They had to extrapolate those
curves.
How do you know how to
extrapolate?
For a decade the curves had
been flat.
Suddenly they're starting to
accelerate.
How do you know how to
extrapolate them?
There's huge uncertainty,
huge volatility,
and so naturally the lenders
are going to be much more
nervous and lend only with much
more collateral.
Once the lenders lend with much
more collateral those people at
the top can't afford to buy
things anymore.
They're going to have to sell.
So there's de-leveraging.
Sorry, and the people at the
top are going to have to sell,
but the price is going to go
down, and because they borrowed
money and using an asset as
collateral,
their leverage--we talked about
that--
their losses are going to be
gigantic because they're
betting,
essentially,
on things going up,
and things are going down so
they lost a huge amount of
money.
So this is always the same
thing.
There is scary bad news.
Margins get tougher,
and the most optimistic
leveraged buyers are the ones
who got crushed because they
were betting on things going up
and they go bankrupt.
So now, what's so bad about
this?
I'm running out of time here,
and I haven't gotten to how the
math is going to change.
So what's so bad?
So I'm going to talk for four
more minutes and hand back the
exams, or should I just hand
back the exams right now?
What do you--are you?
I'll talk four more minutes.
Some of you aren't going to
come next time,
maybe most of you,
so I'll do how the math changes
next time.
So what's so bad about the
leverage cycle?
So let's just think about all
the bad things that happened.
Number one, you can have a tiny
group of people at the top
controlling the price,
because they can borrow so much
money.
Now we've always assumed that
everybody was rational.
What if these buyers are kind
of crazy?
A few guys can make the price
skyrocket because they can
borrow so much money.
Now, once they do that and
they're making the price of
assets skyrocket,
people are going to build more
of those assets.
So they're going to use real
resources to build projects that
are probably crazy and are going
to be very costly to reverse.
But let's leave aside now
people being crazy.
What else happens in the
leverage cycle?
Well, in the leverage cycle
when you're leveraged a lot,
as we said, that's going on the
Tobin diagram to the right.
It's like borrowing money to
bet in the stocks.
That means if the stocks go up
you multiply your winnings.
If the stocks go down you
multiply your losses.
So in the leverage cycle people
who are lucky,
if things keep going up,
they get incredibly rich.
It's a tremendous mystery in
economics.
Why is it that inequality
increased so much?
Well, one of the reasons,
I think, is the leverage cycle,
that people were betting and
making more and more money and
so that's why inequality was--
is helping to spread inequality.
Now, another thing is the
worst, probably the biggest
problem is that once the asset
prices fall everything gets hard
to do.
So if you want to get a new
credit card, what does it mean
to get a credit card?
It means that you sell your
promise, right,
to a buyer.
Now, why should a buyer buy
your promise for 100,
you're promising to pay back in
the future,
so he's paying 100 for you when
the very same promise that
someone made six months ago is
selling for 65 because the
prices have all collapsed.
They're not going to buy the
new promises when they can buy
the old promises at such a low
price.
Who's going to buy a new
mortgage when the old mortgages
are selling at 65?
Who's going to buy a new auto
loan when the old auto loans are
selling so low?
So nobody can get a new loan.
Nobody can sell a new promise,
and no business can sell its
promise.
There are old businesses that
everybody understands whose
bonds are out there being traded
at very low prices.
The investors are going to all
buy the old assets not the new
assets.
That's why activity collapses.
Then another terrible thing is,
what if the optimists are
indispensable to the economy
like the big banks?
They go out of business and
then everything topples.
Well, why didn't the big banks
take that into account?
Shouldn't they have realized
that the losses would be so big
and try to protect themselves?
Well, they're not taking into
account that when they go under
and the managers lose a lot of
money that there are other
people they don't care about
like all their workers and the
rest of the economy that's
losing even more that they're
not paying attention to.
So they're not internalizing
all the losses when they go out
of business.
Another incredibly bad thing
is, what we're suffering from
now is, debt overhang.
There are a tremendous number
of people, homeowners to name
one, who are under water.
That means they owe more money
than their house is worth,
or banks that have more debts
than the value of the assets
they hold,
or firms that have more debt
than the value of the assets
they hold.
Now, many of these people don't
just go bankrupt.
They keep going because maybe
they'll get lucky.
Maybe some miracle will happen
and the stuff they own is going
to go up in value.
So they don't stop.
They still exist,
but they're what people have
called zombies.
They're not doing anything
productive because what's the
point in fixing up your house if
more than likely you're going to
end up losing it anyway.
So all these homeowners are not
doing anything to take care of
their houses,
the banks aren't making loans,
these firms aren't making
productive investments because
they know they're so far under
water.
So another horrible thing
happens is that if you try to
collect the collateral when
people default,
it's a costly operation.
So in sub-prime loans it takes
18 months to throw somebody out
of their house.
So during those 18 months the
guy's not paying his mortgage.
He's not paying his taxes,
all of which you have to make
up for.
He's trashing the house,
or if he doesn't trash it he
leaves the house and some
neighbor trashes it and rips out
everything in the house.
The average sub-prime loan,
when you force someone out of
their house and sell it,
you get back 1 quarter of the
value of the house now.
At the beginning people assumed
it could never be less than 80
percent.
Now it's 1 quarter.
Then there are other more
complicated things that can go
wrong which I'm going to skip
over.
So let's just see what happens
now with housing.
So what is it that's happening
with housing?
If you look at people
underwater, why are people
defaulting on their houses?
It's because they're underwater.
So here is for every different
kind of mortgage,
starting at sub-prime and going
down to prime.
These are except government
loans.
This is the fraction of people
who default every month,
not every year,
and here's their loan to value.
So how did I figure out the
loan to value?
I had to look at all the
original loans.
I did this house by house,
or Ellington,
my hedge fund,
actually the guys there who
were former students here,
they actually figured all this
out.
They went house by house.
They got what the loan sizes
were on all the houses,
and then using the Shiller
index they know what the house
was bought for,
and assuming the zip code index
dropped by 20 percent they
figured every house in the index
went down by 20 percent,
so they could get the current
value of the house.
So this is the ratio of the
loan to the current value of the
house.
Current combined loan to value
ratio.
So 140 means the loans all
together, first and second loans
are 140 percent of what they
estimate the value of the house
is.
So look at what happens.
If you're sub-prime and you've
got that--I can't see my--this
is--140's over here somewhere,
right?
You're defaulting more than 6
percent a month.
If you're 160 you're defaulting
at 8 percent.
Every month 8 percent of those
people are becoming serious
delinquent and probably will
never repay;
8 percent a month.
In one year they're all going
to be gone.
So you can see this is
shockingly sensitive to loan to
value.
It's not that people are
defaulting because they lost
their jobs.
They're defaulting because it's
not worth it for them to pay.
They're not stupid.
Why should they pay 160,000
when the house is only worth
100,000?
It's just how can they,
you know, times are tough.
What are they going to do,
tell their children,
well, we can't feed you?
You can't go to school,
because daddy and mommy have to
pay this thing where we don't
really have to pay it?
They're not going to do it.
So somehow, I couldn't convince
Larry Summers of this,
I tried hard.
I wrote an Op-Ed in The New
York Times in October of
2008.
I wrote another one in 7,
October.
No, a year ago.
What are we talking about,
October of 2008 then March of
2009, saying that the only way
to save the housing market was
to write down principal.
Now, writing down principal
means saying,
if the loan is 160,000,
maybe the house used to be
200,000, the house is only
100,000 now.
You just say,
"We're writing off 80,000
of the loan.
It's now only 80,000 that the
homeowner owes."
Now, who's going to pay for the
lost 80,000?
I say, nobody has to pay for it.
The government doesn't have to
pay a penny.
The bond holder,
the lender would be better off
writing down the loan to 80,000
than throwing the guy out of the
house and getting 40,000 in the
end,
because once the loan is
written down to 80,000 the
homeowner now has 20,000 of
equity in the house.
He'll either work hard to fix
it up and spruce it up and sell
it for 100,000,
or he'll actually pay the
80,000.
Either way the lender is going
to get 80,000,
not 40,000.
So this is a win-win as I
called it in the editorial with
Susan Koniak,
a coauthor, a law professor at
BU.
It's a win-win situation and
it's not happening.
And it's not happening because
the loans are all in the hands
of the servicers.
So remember I said there was
this big pool with all the loans
in them and then there were the
bonds.
And so the bond holders,
these are the people who'd like
to see the principal written
down,
but the bond holders don't know
who the homeowners are and
aren't legally allowed to talk
to them.
There's a servicer in the
middle who's a big bank who's
writing the letter saying pay
up,
and if they pay up they
distribute the money to the bond
holders.
If they don't pay up the
servicer throws them out of the
house.
The servicer,
the big bank doesn't own the
loans.
They're getting paid a
percentage, like .5 percent of
the principal,
so they have no incentive to
write down these loans.
If they write down the loan in
half they lose half their fee.
If they write down the loan to
80,000 and then the guy sells
the house they don't service the
house anymore.
They lose all their fees.
Instead, Obama,
thanks to my classmate Larry
Summers and all his other
advisors,
they've given these servicers
license not to write down any
loans,
but to pretend that they're
writing down the interest on the
loans.
Now, that would be great,
and that's actually what's
happening.
The servicers are basically not
even kicking the people out of
their houses.
So these people are not paying
anything now.
There are millions of them not
paying anything still living in
their houses.
In a year or two they're going
to get thrown out,
but of course they're not going
to pay.
This is the ideal situation for
the servicer because he's still
collecting his fee,
the homeowners can't sell,
they don't want to leave
because they're not paying
anything,
and the bondholders are getting
screwed.
So it's a catastrophe.
And finally,
after a year,
if you read the Op-Ed's in
The New York Times and
the The Wall Street
Journal,
in the last week or two they
have been deluged with people
saying,
"Why aren't they writing
down principal?"
So this is something that a
year or two ago I already
advocated.
Anyone with any common sense
would have seen that was what
was inevitably going to happen
and we didn't do anything about
it.
So I've got one more minute to
finish.
So what should we do about the
leverage cycle?
Well, the thing to do about the
leverage cycle is to reverse the
three bad things that happen in
a leverage cycle.
The first one was that there
was too little--the most
important one is leverage
collapse.
So the Fed has to go and
increase leverage.
So it used to be 30 to 1 or 20
to 1 now it's close to 1 to 1 on
many assets, although it's gone
up a little bit.
So the Fed has actually done
something about this.
What does it have to do?
Not lend at lower interest.
The Fed cut the interest rate
to 0 and said,
"Look how great we
are."
Well, that did nothing
practically.
The reason the Fed has cut the
interest rate to zero is to give
money to the big banks because
the banks have to pay depositors
like you and me.
Now, on your checking account
or savings account you're
getting zero practically because
the Fed lowered the interest
rate to 0.
That means the banks make money
because they don't have to waste
any money giving it to their
depositors.
That's the reason why the
interest rate went down to 0,
and they try to dupe the public
into thinking it's because it's
a Keynesian stimulus.
It's not stimulating anything
basically.
What you have to do is lend
with less collateral and the
banks aren't willing to do it.
The Fed has go around the banks
and lend with less collateral,
which I'm running out of time
so I can't explain how it's
actually done that and that's
one of the big reasons leverage
is starting to go up.
Secondly, you have to replace
some of the natural buyers who
have gone out of business,
the ones at the top who are
doing all the buying.
Without them the price is going
to be worth much less.
The government is going to have
to do some buying.
So through the PPIP program and
other things it is doing some of
that.
And then finally the first
thing, the most important thing,
the crisis began with housing.
Housing is the first thing you
have to do to lessen the
instability and the uncertainty
in the economy.
It's now started with housing
and it spread to other people
who are under water.
That's where all the
uncertainty comes from.
So we have to straighten out
who's going to go out of
business and who's not going to
go out of business.
We have to write down principal
of the homes.
That's the way to reduce that
uncertainty.
And in the long run we have to
prevent the next leverage cycle
by never letting leverage get so
high.
So we have to keep the data and
we have to prevent people from
asking for so little margins.